on peut y arriver tu y crois oui it be
il est l'heure d'aller aux mais on est
en train de vivre une grande aventure
[Musique]
disons que tu es un dieu qui veulent du
mal à tout le monde et parfois comment
toi et warwick
[Musique]
partir à la guerre je veux tu restes
avec nous je veux tu pour toi
l'onu et les états unis on dégage ici on
sert pas les jamais
pas lui rendre visite
sur lequel d'entre vous et l'élu vous
un objet sans vie va soudain se mettre à
bouger mû par la volonté tu peux y
arriver
tu y croies site tu as maintenant le
pouvoir c'est à ton tour tu accomplis
la voici
et marie mai les morts et les vivants
nous l'ignorons
si vous avez de la fois gros comme une
graine de moutarde
rien ne vous sera impossible faut que
j'arrête qui font d'un ta foi ne pourra
fonctionner si jamais il demeure en
toile moindre sentiment de haine qu'est
ce que tu fabriques la traînée prise
venez flâner hockey
pour tulle empêche de croire à ces
conneries empêcher un enfant de 8 ans
d'essayer de venir en aide à son père
bien était plus puissant que la volonté
d'affronter ses peurs afin de pouvoir
agir
j'ai le visage de l'ennemi
[Musique]
je veux faire revenir nos terres
fréquentant ce type en fait c'est au
père que du drive
tu fait déplacer les montagnes ton à une
larve asie c'est un staff
ne te mesure plus à la distance qui le
sépare du sol mesure toi pas la distance
entre toi et le ciel
il n'y a pas plus grand bonhomme dans
cette vie